let me let me ask you about some of
some of joe biden's positions that have
changed i mentioned
he was against the travel ban you know a
few months later oh
it was a great decision uh he said
numerous times in some of the primary
debates he was against
all fracking uh a lot of denial on the
issue of
the violence and the rioting and the
anarchy and cities at one point said
police become the enemy reallocate funds
etc
um now he's talking even about
manufacturing jobs
uh when in his when he was vice
president and obama was president they
said those jobs ain't coming back
that's right why the flip-flops do you
think america is going to be like it
actually
what's up i've never seen anything quite
like it the travel ban all of a sudden
he denies that
thinks it's fine thinks it was good but
how about fracking
and you need that it's basically your
fossil fuels your energies
we would have to close many of the
plants a big percentage of the plants in
our country if we didn't do this we have
these massive plants
and they're not going to run by wind and
they're not going to run by
solar at this point and maybe at no
point
but we have uh natural gas which is
really very environmentally friendly
we have all sorts of things we're the
number one in the world
now in energy we've done a great job
with energy and you look at what you're
paying a price per gallon at your car
people are saying it's unbelievable
they're paying less than two dollars in
many cases and
going down even and they can't believe
how well we've done we don't need to be
in the middle east other than for the
protection of israel
there's no reason to be there from the
standpoint of
oil but we have allies saudi arabia and
others that have been
really spend a lot of money here and
treat us well and
you know we'll take care of a lot of our
people we have some very good allies
over there and israel of course we
helped israel
a lot and we took out solomani
we took out a lot of a lot of problems
they were
having over there or they would have
without us without us i don't think
any of them would survive for very long
so but we don't need it for energy
anymore we're energy independent it's an
incredible feeling i guess it's the
first time we've ever been or at least
for many many decades energy independent
and you look at the price of energy if
if biden never got in he was talking
about no fracking
very strongly and his super liberal
running mate who's the most liberal
person
more so than bernie rated the most
liberal in all of the senate
uh kamala if you look at what she said
about fracking there won't be any fossil
fuels there won't be any fracking
and they're all disciples of aoc and aoc
plus three
and uh it's ridiculous but they
constantly talk about no fracking then
all of a sudden he sees his poll numbers
going down and he sees you know
texas wants oil i say they're against
guns
they're against oil and they're against
religion that doesn't do well in texas
or pennsylvania or north carolina or
just about any other place that i could
think of
and it's a you know it's incredible but
they'll change in an instant and pretend
like nothing ever happened they'll say
oh no
i'm okay with fracking oh but he said it
the other day
uh biden said it the other day he said
no no no
fracking is okay we're going to uh
grandfather it
we're going to do something with it but
fracking's okay and yet he just ran
for months and months where he's
fighting fracking and she i don't think
she could possibly say she's been
fighting a fear but the bottom line
they will go back to where they come
from where they come from
is no oil no fracking no drilling
uh religion look what they're doing to
religion they don't let your churches
open
they let a casino open but they won't
let your churches open they'll let
protesters protest in the streets
without masks by the thousands
but they won't let your churches open so
there it's religion
it's oil and it's guns and those three
items alone
how can anybody even run george
washington and abra
abraham lincoln as a as a combo as a
combination couldn't win
but this is what we're up against they
changed their view but where they're
going from
and where they're going to is where they
originally came from
and that's none of this stuff you're not
going to frack you're not going to have
energy
and our nation's going to have one of
the best years it ever had next year
last year was the best year we've ever
had next year year's going to be better
and this third quarter
coming up and the numbers are going to
be out before the before the election
those numbers are going to be fantastic
you watch well the numbers were at 8.4
percent
unemployment there was some predictions
early on i i didn't
i did not think you'd see the jobs come
back as quickly as they did to be
very frank record settings
so but early voting has started before
the first debate which is scheduled for
september 29th early voting is now going
on
in states uh around the country you've
talked a lot about that
are you preparing yet for your upcoming
debates and if so how so
well a little bit but what i'm concerned
about are all these ballots because
they're sending unsolicited ballots
it could be as many as 80 million
throughout the nation
and when you have small races like a
congressional race in new york
with two people where the ballots are a
mess
84 000 plus yeah if the ballots are
missing
they're gone there there's been fraud
there's been deceit and deception
and this is just a small congressional
race carolyn maloney
a small congressional race and then you
look at new jersey what happened in
paterson what happened in virginia what
happened in
almost every place and these are small
little races that are easy to
you would think it would be very easy
but it's it's terrible and now we're
sending out
80 million ballots and they're
unsolicited
so when you send out that means people
are gonna get ballots
that don't even know they're getting
them and that takes the enthusiasm away
a little bit because we have this
massive the largest ever they say
the difference in enthusiasm but if
people are going to start walking up to
your door and saying do you want to sign
this
they'll say i don't want to vote we'll
sign this okay i'll sign it there's no
enthusiasm necessary there
it's really a corrupt system and you
watch they have a plan
and the plan is not a good plan they
look to tie it all up because
they can't control the ballots on a
small congressional race and smaller
races even than that
and now you're going to control 80
million ballots
i don't think so well attorney general
barr has warned about it the
heritage foundation has identified
almost a thousand convictions on the
issue of voter fraud
almost 1300 examples of voter fraud
uh you know the election is now
anecdotally there's been reports that
maybe your campaign is short on cash i
made some calls today my sources say
that is not the case
yeah i mean a little shy at 300 million
dollars but
i was told by a friend in florida that
that joe biden has
three to one ads running against yours
is this
a strategy you're waiting or is this
something that you didn't want
maybe you're just ramping up after labor
day so four years ago i won it in the
last month
and we have about three times more cash
now than we had then and that's without
me putting up any if i needed extra put
it up myself i just
i said that two days ago i said if
there's any necessary extra cash
but we have a lot of money coming in and
small donors i haven't been heavy on big
donors because i don't want to call them
you know when you call big donors you
you sort of put yourself in a very
compromising position when somebody puts
up a lot of money you're in a
compromised position
whether you say it whether you don't say
it it doesn't matter
and what i like are the small donors but
no we have
substantially more two to three times
more than we had
four years ago at this time and four
years ago we won
but if we needed any more if i saw that
we were going to need more i would put
it up myself
absolutely uh mr president we have an
election
and we have less than 20 seconds for you
an election in just 55 days 20 seconds
what this means to you this election and
what does it mean in the country
if and when we win we're going to have
the greatest economy in the history of
our country it'll be next year and you
will see numbers like you
you have never seen with tax cuts and
regulation cuts
further already done the biggest tax cut
in history
but we're going to do a great job and
we're going to keep our military and our
vets very very happy
mr president from the white house
tonight thank you so much for joining us
thank you very much